[Musique]
les quelques temps j'ai rencontré une
femme
j'ai discuté avec elle longuement et
elle m'a dit qu'elle n'avait pas de
désir qu'elle n'avait plus de désir pour
son mari elle m'a aussi dit qu'avant
pour elle le sexe bon ça ne gênait pas
trop mais que maintenant elle a vraiment
fait comme ça et puis un peu plus loin
dans la discussion
elle m'a dit qu'en fait tu avais jamais
eu d'orgasme et que durant les rapports
elle avait relativement peu de plaisir
alors moi à mon tour je vais parler de
clitoris de lubrification le point g de
lâcher prise et d'orgasme ce que je vous
ai pas encore dit c'est que cette femme
elle a 70 ans
alors là vous êtes peut-être en train de
vous dire mais comment ça se fait qu'il
en vient à discuter de ces choses là
avec une femme de 70 ans et ben moi je
vous dirai pourquoi pas mais en fait
sachez que c'est mon quotidien que c'est
mon métier
en fait je suis médecin gynécologue et
sexologue
alors même si la plupart des femmes
peuvent s'accorder à dire qu'un rapport
sexuel sans orgasme peut être
satisfaisant toutes celles qui l'ont
expérimenté vous diront aussi que c'est
agréable que c'est plutôt brune que
c'est relaxant et puis bah que ça gâche
rien bien au contraire et que ça appelle
même à y revenir
la plupart de mes confrères sexologue
aujourd'hui s'accorde à dire que la
sexualité masculine n'est peut-être pas
aussi simple que ce qu'on veut le dire
mais que la sexualité féminine n'est
peut-être pas aussi complexe et
mystérieuse qu'on laisse sous entendre
depuis longtemps
heureusement quelques années en arrière
quand j'étais étudiant en médecine
la plupart de mes proches venait me
demander des conseils des avis sur leurs
bobos ou la maladie de la grand mère
tout ça c'est normal
j'ai passé le concours de l'internât et
je me suis spécialisé en gynécologie
obstétrique et la balle est copine
venait me poser des questions sur la
grossesse l'accouchement leurs règles ou
les mycoses les copains eux
s'intéressait beaucoup plus aux
anecdotes de sable de garde après
l'internât ben j'ai choisi de m'orienter
vers la médecine de la reproduction pour
faire les fécondations in vitro et je
complétais ça avec deux l'andrologie
l'andrologie c'est tout les difficultés
pour l'homme infertiles le diplôme dans
drôles og
c'est une année de reproduction
masculine et une année de sexualité
masculine et je suis donc devenu
gynécologue obstétricien capable de
traiter une dysfonction érectile ou une
éjaculation prématurée mais totalement
incompétent dans la gestion des troubles
sexuels féminins
alors là pour remédier à ce problème
mais j'ai choisi de faire le diplôme
inter universitaire de sexologie et avec
deux collègues de l'hôpital dans lequel
je me sais eh ben on a dit qu'on va se
lancer dans ce début et là j'ai appris
plein de choses
j'ai appris plein de choses que mes
parents ne m'avait pas apprise au
maintenant était ce leur rôle j'ai
appris plein de choses que les profs de
sciences nat ou les trop rares
intervenants en santé sexuelle que
j'avais pu croiser ne m'avait pas
apprises j'ai appris plein de choses que
mes cours de médecine ne m'avait pas
apprises et enfin j'ai appris plein de
choses que la ville n'avait pas encore
appris nos cours avaient lieu le mardi
soir et tous les mercredi vers 10h à la
pause café avec l'ensemble chef du
service bon débriefait ont leur raconter
ce qu'on avait appris la veille et
bizarrement bas il était super intéressé
il trouvé ça passionnant il posé plein
de questions et puis bah ils apprenaient
plein de choses en fin de 3e année de ce
diplôme j'ai présenté mon mémoire et
j'ai fait sous la direction du docteur
de vaud un mémoire sur les femmes
fontaines et l'éjaculation féminine
c'est un sujet très sérieux ça fait 2
millions qu'on se posait la question
mais quelle était l'origine de la source
d'où ça vient et grâce aux échographies
que j'ai fait et au dosage du haut xingu
biochimiques et ben on a avancé sur le
sujet et ça on l'a publié on a fait un
article
dans une grande revue américaine qui
fait référence en matière de médecine
sexuelle et je m'y attendais pas mais ça
a fait un buzz incroyable j'ai été
sollicité par les journalistes pour
faire des interviews on m'a demandé
d'écrire des articles en plus j'ai
participé à des reportages et j'ai même
écrit un bouquin sur le sujet on m'a
sollicité pour aller parler dans des
congrès et j'ai rencontré plein de gens
plein de gens intéressés plein de gens
intéressants qui m'ont encore appris
plein de choses sur la sexualité et sur
le plaisir et en fait c'est un petit peu
ces choses que j'ai envie de partager
avec vous ce soir la sexualité existe
depuis la nuit des temps
sinon on serait pas là pour en parler
mais pendant très longtemps elle a été
avisé reproductive un peu dominé par une
pression masculine centré sur la
pénétration et surtout sous le diktat de
la religion qui disait qu'une femme
devait avoir un maximum d'enfants et un
minimum d'orgasme et surtout pas le
contraire en 1956 un américain le
docteur gregory pincus a créé la pilule
contraceptive et ça ça a été le début de
la révolution sexuelle et de
l'émancipation de la femme elle a été
autorisée en france en 1967 grâce au
député lucien neuwirth et elle a été
diffusée dans la population telle que
vous la connaissez aujourd'hui que dans
les années 80 c'est relativement récent
mais cette diffusion de la contraception
a permis de séparer la sexualité en deux
parties une sexualité reproductive pour
faire des bébés avec son partenaire et
une sexualité récréatives pour passer du
bon temps avec son ou ses partenaires
bon ya cent ans le docteur sigmund freud
le père de la psychanalyse a déclaré que
le seul orgasme véritable de la femme et
l orgasme vaginal celui de la femme
mature et épanouie et que l'orgasme
clitoridien était celui de la petite
fille immature névroses et complexé de
l'absence de pianiste
bon même si à la fin de sa vie il a
déclaré qu'après 30 ans à avoir étudié
la psychologie féminine
il n'avait toujours pas répondu à la
grande question mais que veulent-elles
vraiment et que pour lui la sexualité
féminine rester le continent noir
cette petite phrase dénigrant clitoris a
fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
de nombreuses femmes qui avait une
sexualité plaisante agréable avec des
orgasmes mais obtenue par la stimulation
du clitoris
alors parlons un petit peu anatomy
maintenant est ce que vous êtes je vais
pas vous faire l'affront de vous
demander où se trouve le clitoris est ce
que vous savez quelle est la taille du
clitoris est ce que quelqu'un sait c'est
bien quelqu'un qui ose se mouiller ouais
je n'ai entendu le clitoris mesure entre
8 et 12 cm je vais vous le montrer en 3d
en taille réelle
voilà un clitoris à l'extérieur vous
avez le gland qui va mesurer entre 5 et
10 mm et à l'intérieur la partie
immergée de l'iceberg avec les corps
latéraux les corps caverneux et les
bulbeuses spongieux bah en fait
anatomiquement c'est la même chose qu'un
pénis en brio logiquement ça a la même
origine
sauf que le pénis est en longueur et
clitoris est en arche de chaque côté du
vagin tenez vous laisse je me fais
circuler
prenez en soin c'est un clitoris c'est
fragile et sensible
vous pouvez le faire circuler c'est une
australienne
le docteur hélène o'connell qui en deux
en 1998 a décrit de l'anatomie du
clitoris tels que je voulais montrer
vous avez bien entendu 1980 18
c'était hier c'est en 2010 que la
française odile buisson
une gynécologue a décrit la mécanique du
clitoris ses mouvements et sa
stimulation au cours du rapport sexuel
encore une fois c'est tout récent les
travaux sur le clitoris
ça va pas intéresser grand monde pendant
longtemps puisque c'est un organe
uniquement dédié au plaisir féminin et
qui est un peu de pathologies sachez
pour information que c'est en 2017
cette année à la rentrée que pour la
première fois le clitoris a été
représenté dans son intégralité dans les
manuels pour les cours de svt au collège
cette année 2010 est alors aujourd'hui
clairement on en est revenu du débat
freudien sur les clitoridienne et les
imaginales on sait que le plaisir sexuel
des femmes passent par le clitoris
maintenant vouloir faire jour une femme
sans son clitoris
mais en fait ça reviendrait à vouloir
essayer de faire jouer un homme sur son
pénis c'est pas impossible mais c'est
pas le plus simple
en pratique le clitoris peut être
stimulé de trois manières différentes
tout d'abord direct sur le gland avec
les frottements du pubis le doigt la
langue ou laisse extérieur qui vont
vibrer à haute fréquence et sachez que
sur le plan du clitoris qui entre six et
huit mille terminaisons nerveuses sur le
gland du pénis qui lui est beaucoup plus
large en a que quatre mille donc c'est
relativement sensible c'est relativement
efficace ensuite ils les mouvements de
pénétration les mouvements de
pénétration du pénis qui va et vient et
qui vont étirer les petites lèvres
et si vous regardez bien en eau les
petites lèvres fini sur le frein du
clitoris et se dédouble pour faire le
capuchon du clitoris et donc ces
mouvements de frottement bah ça peut
marcher aussi
et enfin il ya l'étirement latéral la
distension latéral du vagin qui en fait
va frotter les corps spongieux
les bulbes et caverneux et qui vont
donner une simulation différentes
nouvelles intéressantes et pas
désagréable
alors vous l'avez compris le clitoris a
vraiment un rôle central dans la
sexualité féminine mais clairement
aujourd'hui il est sous utilisé il est
sous-exploité je vais vous parler de
quelques chiffres
66% des femmes hétérosexuelles on
déclare avoir systématiquement ou très
régulièrement des orgasmes au cours des
rapports
c'est pas mal nous on est quand même
loin des 95 % d'hommes est plus
intéressant si on s'intéresse aux femmes
homosexuelles
elles sont 86% dans cette catégorie
alors on pourrait se poser la question
du pourquoi alors certains diront que
bah oui une femme connais mieux
l'anatomie de la femme donc elle sait
quoi faire et des plus à droite plus
dextre hockey d'autres diront que ben
les femmes utilisent des sextoys et
comme je vous ai dit qu'ils étaient
parfaitement profit les jeux super bien
utilisé eh bien ça peut marcher
ok mais peut-être que la vraie raison
c'est que en fait quand deux femmes sont
ensemble elles prennent le temps elles
prennent le temps de s'occuper l'une de
l'autre et qu'elles sont pas pressés et
qu'elles ne vivent pas la pression de la
pénétration environ 30% des femmes
seulement arrive à avoir un orgasme par
la pénétration vaginale exclusive vous
avez compris que la pénétration c'était
pas forcément le meilleur outil quand il
est utilisé seul pour donner du plaisir
à une femme c'est clitoris est un
élément majeur du plaisir féminin
il n'est pas seul au 19e siècle
un écossais alexander ce qu'elle a
décrit des petites glandes autour de
l'urètre elle les appelait les glandes
de skene cent ans plus tard
mezzavia zikin huglo slave en 1990 à
réétudier ses glandes et en fait il a
montré que l avait exactement la même
composition que c'était exactement le
même tissu que la prostate que la
prostate chez l'homme et donc le concept
de prostate féminine est apparu ça a
même été reconnue par la fédération
internationale d'anatomie et donc les
femmes ont une prostate qui va faire
entre 2 et 5 grammes alors qu'elle fait
entre 20 et 40 grammes chez l'homme elle
est parfaitement fonctionnel
elle est capable d'éjaculer elle est
capable d'émettre un petit liquide
blanchâtre de moins d'un mille litres
très discret et qui contient la même
chose que chez l'homme sauf bien sûr les
spermatozoïdes
maintenant ne confondez pas un c'était
jacut lâcher la femme n'a rien à voir
avec l'émission liquidienne des femmes
fontaines et n'a rien à voir avec la
lubrification
est ce que vous savez d'où vient la
en fait contrairement à ce que beaucoup
pensent il ya pas de glandes
alors oui ici il ya les glandes de
bartholin à l'entrée du vagin au niveau
de la fourchette en bas mais elles sont
très accessoire elle dut griffi un tout
petit peu en fait durant l'excitation
sexuelle
on a une hyper pression il ya un afflux
de sang autour des organes qui va créer
en fait une pression dans les
capillaires et on va avoir une fuite du
plasma donc c'est en fait l'ensemble du
l'âge un kit rang sud et c'est grâce à
ce transfert à cette lubrification bas
que le rapport peut coulisser etc c'est
agréable pour les deux partenaires
alors je vous ai parlé de clitoris de
prostate de vagin de lubrification
comment ne pas parler de sexualité
féminine sans évoquer le point g est ce
qu'il existe
est ce que c'est un mythe alors en fait
tout commence en 1950 quand le docteur
ernest grafenberg publie un papier sur
le rôle de l'urètre dans le plaisir
féminin est en fait il reprend des
témoignages de patients qui lui disent
que quand on stimule la paroi antérieure
du vagin va c'est agréable
c'est bon c'est voluptueux ça donne du
plaisir l'article 2 grafenberg ya eu peu
d'écho à l'époque et ses trente ans plus
tard
klein diego quand il a travaillé sur
l'éjaculation féminine
à retrouver cette paroi antérieure comme
une zone gâchette et donc il l'a appelée
la grafenberg spot le point de
grafenberg le point g alors en fait on a
essayé de chercher pour savoir qu'est ce
qu'il y avait derrière ça on a cherché
ce qui est un organe ce qui a quelque
chose mais en fait on n'a rien trouvé va
pas trouver un organe mais on a plutôt
retrouvé la réunion de plusieurs organes
que je viens de vous décrire le clitoris
en arche l'urètre la prostate autour et
en dessous le vagin et sa forme
aujourd'hui le complexe [ __ ] rideau une
rétro prostate au vaginale on va dire le
point g pour faire simple et donc ce
point g bah il se localise ou mais en
fait il est sur la paroi antérieure à
2,3 cm il a une consistance un petit peu
différente un petit peu plus granuleuse
et quand on appuie tuba c'est agréable
alors je voudrais placer quelques
repères anatomiques qui pourront
peut-être aidé à certaines femmes à
mieux se connaître ou certains hommes à
être un petit peu moins perdu et en tout
cas pour qu'une femme puisse jouir pour
qu'elle puisse avoir des orgas il ya
quelques prérequis
tout d'abord il va falloir qu'elles se
connaissent il va falloir qu'elle
connaisse son anatomie son intimité sa
physiologie sa réponse à la stimulation
sexuelle et ça clairement c'est une
invitation à l'auto exploration et à la
masturbation
ensuite il va falloir qu'elle se libère
il va falloir qu'elle se libère de 2000
ans d'éducation judéo chrétienne ou
d'une éducation familiale un petit peu
stricte dans laquelle le plaisir féminin
et le désir féminin était tabou salle on
te voir même réprimées enfin pour qu'une
femme puisse jouir
il va falloir qu'elle soit capable de
lâcher prise qu'elles soient capables de
déconnecter une petite zone dans le
cerveau qui est juste ici dans le cortex
orbitofrontal qui en fait la zone du
qu'en dira-t-on
et donc si elle arrive à déconnecter
cette zone eh ben elle peut se laisser
envahir par toutes les sensations
agréables et voluptueuse qui vont monter
de la simulation de ses organes mais
pour pouvoir déconnecté cette zone pour
lâcher prise la qualité de la relation
avec le partenaire est indispensable
alors le partenaire lui il doit être
informée patients s'intéresser à sa
partenaire avant lui
altruiste les mouvements de la mécanique
sexuelle qui vont donner du plaisir aux
hommes ne sont pas forcément ceux qui
vont donner du plaisir à la femme c'est
pas les mêmes mouvements c'est pas la
même mécanique et comme on sait que la
femme peut être multi orgasmique qu'elle
peut avoir plusieurs orgasmes dans le
même rapport dans la même soirée mais
que le rapport généralement prend fin
quand monsieur a joui éjaculer bas vous
l'avez compris messieurs prenez le temps
de vous intéresser à vos femmes d'accord
donnez leur du plaisir et elles seront
voulons rendre aujourd'hui il est temps
de sortir des sentiers battus de laisser
tomber nos schémas ancestraux d'une
sexualité trop classique tester innover
jouer et prenez du plaisir
alors pour revenir à la patiente que
j'avais vus en consultation
bah je les dis tout ce que je vous ai
dit ce soir
enfin presque quasiment tôt elle a été
surprise mais aussi curieuse intéressés
et elle m'a dit avoir appris plein de
choses
et avant de partir elle m'a demandé si
elle pouvait revenir avec son mari pour
que je lui passe les mêmes informations
c'est peut-être de là qu'est venue
l'idée de vous faire cette soirée je
vous ai donné beaucoup d'informations ce
soir peut-être vous avez appris des
choses peut-être pas si c'est le cas
c'est que vous êtes des experts je vous
remercie de votre attention je vous
laisse profiter des derniers topo et
puis bah rend très bien et amusez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]